voici un microscope à force atomique
métrologique cet outil de pointe unique
en france fait partie des équipements du
nouvel institut ellen nanotech intégré
au sein du laboratoire national d'essai
et de métrologie
l'institut est en charge de la
réalisation des références à l'échelle
du nanomètre
il a notamment comme objectif de
développer les nanotechnologies vous
avez des applications par exemple sur
l'équipe dkr autonettoyante n'ai plus
besoin de nettoyer vos carreaux vous
avez des textiles qui ne sentent pas
mauvais parce qu'ils sont anti bactérien
vous avez des applications dans la santé
extrêmement importante
par exemple dans le traitement de
certains cancers
depuis plus de dix ans au ellen cette
équipe de recherche travaillent sur les
nanomatériaux et les nano dispositif une
activité en plein essor appelé à jouer
un rôle important dans le monde de
demain
c'est absolument clé pour l'industrie et
en particulier toute une série
d'industries innovantes dans le domaine
du semiconducteur dans le mais aussi
dans le domaine alimentaire
pharmaceutique puisque les nanomatériaux
sont de plus en plus utilisés dans
l'industrie pour leurs propriétés
particulières une nouvelle technologie
source d'inquiétude d'où l'utilité de ce
nouvel institut sont des particules tout
petit qui peuvent franchir les barrières
biologiques de façon avec des propriétés
tout à fait incroyable et donc il faut
mieux les connaître mieux les
caractérise et c'est ce qu'on va faire
ici objectif pour l'institut ellen
nanotech devenir un opérateur de
référence au niveau national mais aussi
international